SURGE OF COVID HOSPITALIZATIONS
AND DOCTORS SAY MOST OF THE KIDS
ARE UNVACCINATED.
>> Reporter: 4-MONTH-OLD GRAYSON
PERRY, HIS TINY BELLY RAPIDLY
EXPANDING AND CONTRACTING.
ONE OF MANY CHILDREN HERE WITH
COVID-19.
STRUGGLING TO BREATHE.
>> ARE YOU AFRAID THEY'LL HAVE
TO INTUBATE HIM?
>> YEAH.
A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S JUST REALLY SCARY.
SO I JUST HOPE THAT, YOU KNOW,
HE'S ABLE TO GET BETTER AND GO
HOME.
>> Reporter: MOM TO THREE, SEEMS
HER YOUNGEST PICKED UP THE VIRUS
AT A FAMILY CHRISTMAS GATHERING.
HER ONLY JOB NOW, KEEPING HER
SON IN GOOD SPIRITS.
>> I DO TALK TO HIM IN A LITTLE
BABY VOICE.
I SING TO HIM.
I CAN'T SING, BUT HE LIKES IT.
>> ONE OF NEARLY 70 CHILDREN NOW
HOSPITALIZED AT TEXAS
CHILDREN'S.
A NEW RECORD HIGH FOR THE
NATION'S LARGEST PEDIATRIC
HOSPITAL.
IN JUST THE LAST TWO WEEKS,
HOSPITALIZATIONS HERE HAVE
INCREASED MORE THAN FOURFOLD.
MOST UNVACCINATED OR NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR VACCINES FROM
TODDLERS TO TEENS.
>> OUR COVID JOURNEY BEGAN -- WE
BEGAN NOVEMBER 29th.
ME AND MY DAUGHTER BOTH TESTED
POSITIVE FOR COVID.
>> AMY WOODRUFF'S DAUGHTER, HER
17th BIRTHDAY THE DAY WE VISITED
HAS BEEN INTUBATED IN AN INDUCED
COMA FOR NEARLY A MONTH.
SHE ALSO GAVE BIRTH NEARLY THREE
WEEKS AGO.
SHE KNOWS NONE OF IT.
>> SHE HAD A C-SECTION IN
AMARILLO ON DECEMBER 9th.
TO A BEAUTIFUL LITTLE BABY GIRL,
3 POUNDS, 6 OUNCES.
>> SHE HAS NOT SEEN YET.
>> SHE HAS NOT SEEN.
AND SHE WAS COVID NEGATIVE,
PRAISE JESUS.
>> Reporter: FROM TEXAS, SHE WAS
MOVED TO AMARILLO, THEN HOUSTON
FOR ADVANCED CARE.
STILL UNAWARE HER 3-WEEK-OLD
DAUGHTER IS 900 MILES AWAY IN AN
AMARILLO NEWBORN INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT.
>> WHAT WILL YOU TELL HER WHEN
YOU CAN SPEAK TO HER?
>> I DON'T EVEN WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
THAT'S MY LITTLE GIRL BEING AWAY
FROM HER LITTLE GIRL.
MY HEART BLEEDS FOR HER.
>> Reporter: THE OMICRON VARIANT
NOW RIPPING THROUGH THE LONE
STAR STATE.
TEXAS CHILDREN'S PREPARING FOR
EVEN MORE SICK KIDS AS COVID-19
CASES SKYROCKET.
>> WHAT IS YOUR SENSE FOR WHAT
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS ARE GOING TO
HOLD?
>> I THINK THE BAR FOR
RESILIENCE JUST KEEPS MOVING.
YOU THINK THAT I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE CAN DO THIS AGAIN AND THEN WE
KEEP DOING IT AGAIN.
>> AS TEXAS CHILDREN'S READIES
FOR A FOURTH CORONAVIRUS WAVE.
ALREADY ITS ER IS SEEING A SPIKE
IN KIDS SUFFERING MILD SYMPTOMS.
THEIR PARENTS SEEKING TESTING,
BOGGING DOWN TRIAGE FOR THE
SERIOUSLY ILL.
>> WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
PATIENTS PRESENT WITH MILD
RESPIRATORY SYMPTOMS, COUGH,
CONGESTION, FEVER, KNOWN COVID
EXPOSURES THAT A LOT OF THEM ARE
REALLY SEEKING TESTING.
>> LIKE PREVIOUS WAVES, THE
SICKEST KIDS, THOSE NEEDING
HOSPITALIZATION, ARE HAVING A
TOUGH TIME BREATHING.
>> SO THEY'RE GETTING A LOT OF
RESPIRATORY SYMPTOMS AS WE'VE
BEEN EXPECTING.
PNEUMONIA, NEEDING RESPIRATORY
SUPPORT TO HELP THEM BREATHE
BETTER.
>> Reporter: VIRAL SPREAD
EXPECTED TO INTENSIFY IN THE
WEEKS AHEAD AND EVEN IF THE
OMICRON VARIANT ISN'T AS
SEVERE --
>> THE PROBLEM IS THAT WITH SO
MANY CHILDREN AND ADULTS
INFECTED, EVEN IF THE PERCENT --
PERCENT HOSPITALIZATION RATE IS
LOWER, WE'RE STILL COU